and students will also have access to
the omic Strategic resources but how
does it help Advance bioinformatics
teaching omic's logic is a portal for
practical and theoretical learning of
bioinformatics it takes a combination of
training modules data analysis tools
curated project data sets and
interactive sessions with mentors to
give the student a clear path of the
Bloom's taxonomy permit and no matter
what the user's initial experience with
bioinformatics is omic's logic is a
useful tool for gaining a baseline
knowledge of the theory behind
bioinformatics analysis of large data
sets and introduction to basic coding
languages like R and python or even
beginning a data analysis project
and this also comes with an access to
the example projects of different fields
which you could learn from and replicate
for your research
and users will also be given directions
to access the T by info platform for
bioinformatic processing and Analysis of
data and the platform includes demo
pipelines as well as data management and
Analysis Cloud infrastructure to run the
bioinformatic pipelines and different
stages of analysis are performed in
different sections on this multi-amix
platform
another important resource that you will
get as a part of the program is access
to the omics logic code playground which
will help you develop coding skills
while learning popular packages in
Python to visualize annotate and analyze
complex patterns in biological data in
addition you will also get access to the
Google collab mobiles as a part of the
training program
and with so much data available on any
biological topic and question completing
a program seems like great opportunity
but it can be challenging and that is
why you also have the opportunity to
seek Mentor guidance and learn alongside
an International Community of
bioinformatics and data science
enthusiasts now as a part of the
biomedical data science in Python
program you will be mainly going through
three major coursework which includes
getting started with bioinformatics this
is suitable for those participants who
do not have a previous background in
Python and here in this course you will
be learning data visualization creating
DNA DNA replication and reverse
complements using python and once you
have finished cleaning a basic knowledge
of python you can next advance to data
science courses and to learn logical
aspects of data science one can refer to
the machine learning for biomedical data
course which will teach you about the
statistical methods where unsupervised
and unsupervised machine learning
methods will be used for analyzing
biomedical data followed by this we will
be going one step further and learning
more in depth about the data science
using Python and here are elements of
data science such as data wrangling
visualization statistical analysis and
machine learning will be taught much
more in depth in the same python
and so now to view the various courses
and example projects on the omixological
and portal you need to first sign up on
the portrait before that let me walk you
through a brief demo on what a completed
profile on the portal looks like
so once you sign up on the learn portal
these are the features that you need to
update on your account which includes a
profile image full name with appropriate
capitalization link to your social media
handles
a brief by about yourself that will
consist of your educational background
and research interests and the mentors
can view your activity under the
activity tab the courses you are
currently completing will show up under
the courses Tab and finally once you
complete the courses the certificates
will appear under the certificates that
and so now with that let us Begin by
signing up on the omics logic learn
portal
I am sharing the link to the learn
portal in the chat box
all right so for now those participants
who do not have a previous account on
the portal let me show you how you can
sign up so you can simply click on the
tab this is create an account option
that you see here and here you can
simply enter your name email ID and give
a password or you also have the option
to log in using any of your social media
handles uh so this could be your Google
Facebook Apple account GitHub account or
even Twitter
and for those participants who already
have an account on the portal you can
simply click on login now option and
sign in and so with that I would like to
pause for a couple of seconds so that
the participants can sign up on the
portal so once you have done sign up on
the portal please put a yes in the chat
box and if you already have an account
on the portal please put it done in the
chat box so that I can get a fair idea
about the participants
I'll pause for a couple of seconds I'm
monitoring the chat
all right monalysis is done
uh please make sure to sign up on the
portal so that uh along with today's
webinar the program enter will be
showing you the various resources that
you will be getting as a part of the
program and to take a look at it it will
be important that you have the account
on the portal all right so we do have
few done
in the chat box
all right I'm waiting for the 45 plus
participants to
uh let me know
all right so I do have couple of uh yes
in the chat box so I'm going to sign in
on the portal since I already have an
account on the portal but along the way
if you're having any queries please put
them in the chat box
so once you sign up on the portal uh
this is the main uh page that you will
be seeing so here when you scroll down
uh you'll see a search bar that's asked
for looking for a specific course so
here you can simply enter the keyword
that you're looking for so for instance
if you are interested look for python
courses simply enter the keyword Python
and that will show up the various
courses and example projects that makes
use of a python so here is the first
course that I was talking about where
for those participants who are new to
the feel of uh python then you can get
started with this course and turn the
link in the chat box so that
participants can take a look at it and
this uh course the python 2 course is
much more advanced and these four
participants who already have a prior
knowledge of python so you can
go through it and have a look at various
courses and example projects that are
there so now going to the uh part where
you need to update your profile for this
you need to click on the tab that says
welcome back with your email ID
so once you click here you'll see an
icon that's just profile so once you
click on this you will be able to update
your profile image you can put your full
name make sure that it is in proper
capitalization add a buy about yourself
here I've added my education background
and my research interest and finally you
can link your social media handles as
well so in my case I've linked my
LinkedIn account and my archive